I don't know I don't know how many they
also say to you
sorry was that she let me go sorry let
me go please listen listen off one thing
I guess I'm included in all of us
we care about your life and we love you
and everybody's got a different opinion
about where about what you're doing and
forget him
alright
some in here
you're going off on it you do you start
a new life a new path and more happy for
you man
you've meant a lot to Robert
and I want you to know that what's up a
place to stay
can you come back
actually never even told you this but I
mean if it wasn't for you I wouldn't be
standing here I don't know if you really
remember but uh we had a conversation
and I was I was pretty lost but you know
I had you know just got out of school
didn't know what that was you know and
you were like I'm out here just come and
I'm lightyear mu by I'm alone I you like
you do know somebody know me I'll never
forget that conversation man i'll never
forget that
it's all me don't be afraid just take
that first step right and the next up
will follow us at you Sarah and I did
and it's an unbelievable man spends
phenom believe what man i love you and
you not see you soon
up there ya go man come on already
embarrassed yeah what no game in you
guys just me y'all Besim you know I just
it goes without saying that that's just
fact that you guys have come here and
showing such love so overwhelming and I
hasn't really sunk and it's just kind of
you know I've just spent a lot of times
this week really really examining my
place like goodness in the city in this
in this world and I've really kind of
racked my brain and was it all
worthwhile you know what I mean was it
was it just like was it doomed from the
start I mean with it just like a stupid
pipe dream and I really i mean i still
want i'm still asking those questions I
don't know it's been a very it's bad
spin a truly rough yes we um
um and anyway I don't even out to be
honest the only thing I want right now
is I want to talk to somebody i'm sure
i'll come up to you and say i love you
more but i just i can't think about
anything but this so I'm just gonna I'll
be right back
this is lovely smells like barbecue
can offer me a beer you want a beard
yeah I'm kind
that
thank you
burning down LA on your way out huh so
what wow you showing up to well what do
i owe you showing up at my house Touche
I'm sorry was so awkward he's been
forever no I know I know yeah but what
but you shouldn't feel awkward well I
mean I was and I'm sorry I just was in
complete shock all right so yeah so why
are you leaving what what are what why
are you leaving what when are you
leaving eight hours I don't know what
time is it I'm leaving first thing in
the morning I'm coffee going back to
where I came from is there something
waiting for you there nothing's way my
old life is waiting I guess it's like so
easy for you to look beautiful and
neither that sounds like a line but I
you know I spent well I'm kind of glad
I'm I good at a line is that would make
me pretty cheesy but I I'm not gonna ask
you I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you that
that you your that see now I messed it
up how'd you mess up just to come to DC
with me can you just come with me
Wow you wouldn't have come here in this
beautiful dress if you didn't want to
come with me to DC I mean why now but
why I'm different now Matt I have a
live-in boyfriend I'm moving forward in
my life my medulla do you love him yeah
I do
I mean did you ever wonder before this
point like what if
I just wanted to let you know that I've
always believed in you and I really hope
that you you really find what you're
looking for okay let me ask you this all
right please please oh please don't if I
stayed if I stayed here if I said I'm
staying in LA just for you what would
you say that no
well come on back to the party
for you leaving I think this isn't a
good idea why does nothing ever work out
for me nothing ever works out story of
my life I came here to give you this
because yours and to say goodbye
the right way
and always really care about you
after all that kiss on the cheek
part of me says you know like because
I've abandoned my dream I've let I've
let everyone else actually I've let
family down and let friends down well
you guys are speaking you know putting
me on a pedestal sink powerful
you know how talented I am not
passionate I am but
but in reality it's got to be no way
you're leaving us yeah it's gonna take
off for a little while could be a lot
could be a long while undetermined
undetermined item so it's gonna take a
life time of grieving I mean at least a
lifetime it really is i don't know what
i mean i-i can't see myself ever
forgiving myself for doing this and go
stag apps a point i got something that I
want everybody to see this was in the
oven the whole time oh yeah potential
for you Oh see a better cake and beer
hahaha I'm a man of my word tonight and
I said that I was gonna quit seven years
after I started and Here I am you know
so
thank you for having a yam addict for
coming absolutely I'm gonna see it i'll
see you again he had taken eating too
dog shut up I bet you're out of safe
journey thank you don't worry guys thank
you made it Josie against and you see
you have no keys haha drink me at needed
nice crazy he's so cool he's all over
the place oh yeah this is now the [ __ ]
God as you know about my party that's a
good question man cuz I didn't auntie
hear from you you never told me why did
you tell me I actually got a text
message from Philippe I had a careful
Philippe man that's crazy no no but you
I what you can't hold that against you
tell me man what do you mean why are you
weren't listening you had you you were
talking your manager and your [ __ ] on
the fight it I couldn't talk to you you
know that but you know how it is I would
have had to like shook your ass and told
you and your spice doesn't she shoulda
did all right but I'm here done okay you
know the last time I saw you with this
pseudo Iowa what it was uh I was in your
dad water for you from your graduation
present yeah man I was a long time ago
my god the leaves right there this suit
the suit is seriously like at least ten
years old 15 maybe even serious and I
got some mileage out of this so you got
to make that move yeah so um
you know I'm leaving tomorrow hey you
know there's not much not much here for
me so you know so what are you plans oh
[ __ ] oh my god I I was back in the
laundry room area I guess and I'm
checking my messages cuz I cuz last
night i'm packing i got calls i didn't
relieve in check my messages I got a
[ __ ] audition for the Bruckheimer but
what for one of the [ __ ] lead network
could graduate and I mean it's just an
audition I was like when is it was
autism to tuesday but just let's link to
more [ __ ] it's Tuesday when I don't
know it's on my machine I know so still
not leaving no no I mean I'm you know
well we know what do you mean
every success story seems to have this
sob story in the beginning so cry me a
river let me hear your sob story yeah
man I'm no different when my
girlfriend's let me sleep in this
country like three months man it was
crazy swings coming off the couch man up
they all met him a shout out to my man
Matt ebit be
you
i would say men i would say a lot of it
is god of course you know just being
blessed you know i think i think timing
is a huge percentage of it and it's
definitely some luck in there
you
I mantises Brenda calling you from
travis's office in MDR we did get you in
on that Bruckheimer pilot you're gonna
be auditioning tomorrow at 5pm
e
the song
Oh
I
we try
you
scars
showing strong
I have to give up
try
Oh